I love when non-australians react to
just because like I've tried to convince
so many of my friends especially
Japanese friends to come to Australia
and the first thing they always say is
like yeah but the spiders
is it that bad I I have I haven't seen
one yeah it's not that bad right no how
many of you have actually had any
experience with a spider in your house
like a [__] off oh you you're absolutely
Liars you are absolutely Liars all right
all right oh it's not that bad is it
like once a year
twice a year it's like once a month
right yeah once a month yeah no burning
the [__] house down no but no but I
can explain I can explain uh because uh
because you know we have tons of
different spiders right but the the
spider that always [__] shows up into
the house is the huntsman spider
[Applause]
because the huntsman spider is an
Australian's best friend oh okay okay
why is it Australia's best friend
because I've seen pictures of the Hansen
yeah
I'm not gonna lie they look terrifying
but the the huntsman spider is good
because
um if you see a huntsman spider on your
wall or your ceiling or whatever that
means that you have either an
infestation of flies or mosquitoes in
your house and the Huntsman spider makes
a bro move and he's like dog don't worry
about it I'mma eat them all and then get
the [__] out I know so what you do is if
you see a huntsman spider on your wall
or your ceiling you just leave him be
[__] off no I do you leave him be
because it's like he's he's cleaning up
this is this true is that what you guys
do no it's not yes it is you you are you
telling me if there was like four giant
spiders above your like bed you're like
ah just I'll leave Steve to the morning
you know like brush them away and then
they'll just [__] run away so it's
like I used to have one as a pet all
right so
I used to catch flies rip off their
wings and then give it to the Huntsman
oh
yeah yeah no wonder it's not [__]
leaving your house and then we get a
four meal course every day and then one
day I woke up and he was gone and I was
like good knowing you bro
he's moved on to a different house
so what spiders do we need to look out
for war animals in like your day-to-day
life so so the rule of thumb with like
spiders or snakes in Australia is that
the more colorful they are the more
[__] up they are so we have uh so we
have the uh the red back spider
which is like you don't [__] with him
what is it what do I get bitten by what
happens you die
yeah okay it's straight up all right
important question is this tour in
school like Australian school okay okay
yeah very good I used to in my
kindergarten uh there was this massive
uh poster of like all the different
species of uh like commonly seen spiders
and snakes uh that they would just like
have on the wall and I remember some
like lessons we were like three or four
years old I don't know if this was just
my kindergarten but it was like big like
A3 poster of all these snakes and
spiders and they'd be like okay kids if
you see any of these then cry to your
mum and dad and Don't Go Near any of
them because you will die and all the
kids are like okay it's like it's just
ingrained into you as an Australian
because it's like survival the fittest
in this country that's why we only have
26 million people live how the [__] how
the [__] did any of those like British
people that came here like survive I
just feel like we're just not built for
this no no like the worst we have is
like a goose
you guys have foxes right yeah but foxes
foxes bro every dude this is okay I'm
gonna rant now because this is like
children books making foxes seem like
they're the worst thing ever yeah they
don't [__]
is smart enough to know to know like a
big they're like [__] that I'm gonna go
get like a sheep they can't do anything
they don't do anything they
time when I saw them in London they
were inceptional with snakes and spiders
in Australia as well is that like snakes
are [__] [__] like they like if
you the only reason why they bite people
is for defense mechanism it's because
people are going up to them being like
oh look at the [__] snake and then
they just start like slapping this [__]
around and it's like yeah that's a
typical Aussie thing to do right it's
like like it's like no wonder you'll get
you'll get a bit and you're harassing
the hell out of six
do anything have you ever needed to get
rid of a snake in your house uh yeah
who's had a snake in their house yeah
that's right all right do you have to do
it yourself or is there like someone to
call to get ready have I told this story
on trash day so I don't remember no
you've never told a snake Okay so uh
trash days it was so there's been a
couple of instances but the one that's
just forever ingrained into my mind is
uh I was in high school I was like year
10 or something and I was coming back
from school and because both my parents
were working you know they'd come back
like at night so I would usually be the
first one home so I I'd walk in and uh
my my entrance way was basically this
like two-door system whereas like we had
a steel gate that you'd open okay okay
yeah and then you'd walk in take your
shoes off and then there'd be the main
door to get into the house see that's
how you know the country is [__] up
little bugs and [__] yeah in the UK we
don't have that we barely have a door it
barely works half the time so there was
the the two things right so you'd have
to open the gate first before you can
open the door
um and so I I put the key in I unlock it
and I try and open it and it's just like
not moving at all it's like kind of
stuck and I'm like [__] I unlocked it
what's going on and I'm looking around
and I look up and there's a tree snake
right here
like looking at my face
um and the first instinct as an
Australian is not oh [__] that's a snake
it's [__] I don't know if that's
venomous or not
so what I did in a fit of panic I don't
know if you've ever just like looked
over and the snake's face is just right
here but it scares the [__] out of you
right so I I'm like oh [__] and I swing
it open and the snake runs behind the uh
the the shoe cabinet
right and I'm like and and now I'm in a
pickle I'm like well I can't open the
main entrance because the snake's
probably gonna get in and that's just a
whole other issue and also I don't want
to do anything to the snake because I
I'm not smart enough to identify what it
is all right so I don't know if I'm
stupid I can't do anything so I'm just
like I don't know if that's venomous or
not I'm not gonna do anything but in
Australia I don't know if you guys have
this in Melbourne but uh there is a
hotline that you can call uh called
snake Patrol
they really they really couldn't think
of a better name yeah no well I mean the
name speaks for itself right so I'm like
so I remembered I was like that's right
we have snake Patrol here so I called
him up and I'm like uh and and this like
real [__] Yobo like answers the phone
and he's just like oh wait what
I'll explain I'll explain that to you
later
like he picks up the phone old guy and
he was just like uh and I was like oh
yeah uh I got a snake uh and I I need
help and he was like all right I'll be
there in five minutes
and uh sure enough five minutes later
this guy comes out rocks up walks
towards the door and he's like all right
where's the [__] snake
and I'm just like uh right there and he
just like he looks down like this looks
at it for about 20 seconds and he's like
oh yeah that's a tree snake
and then he walks off
so all the snake Patrol is there to do
is to basically identify if the snake is
poisonous or not if it is poisonous then
he'll go to his truck and get all the
necessary like tools to remove it safely
if it's not poisonous then he's like you
can do it
so basically what I had to do was you
know I'm like 15 16 right like I'm like
okay I know this thing isn't gonna kill
me but I don't I don't want to get
bitten it'll still hurt so I was
basically just like sitting there for 40
minutes just staring at this thing
waiting for my dad to come home and I'm
like don't you [__] move my dad's
gonna
sure enough my dad rocks up I tell him
the situation my dad does the exact same
thing like does this
I was like oh yeah that's a tree snake
walks off no
and uh and my dad just literally just
pulls his arm under
grabs the snake
like in the hand and just goes all right
get in
and that's the moment I knew to never
[__] with my dad
and that's a and I feel that's a very uh
I feel that's a very common story here
in Australia is because sometimes snakes
get curious and they're like oh this
looks like a warm comfortable home I can
turn into my new Abode let's let's try
and get in and then yeah so like all
those videos You See online of like
snakes in the kitchen that's quite
common
[__] you know especially if you're in
like rural Australia like that [__]
happens all the time